-Here at "The Tonight Show,"
we love songs,
and we especially love songs
written by
our audience members
in under an hour.
It's time for a "Battle
of the Instant Songwriters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Sittin' solo
and I'm singing a song ♪
♪ And I'm writing a song
about another song ♪
-Welcome to "Battle of
the Instant Songwriters."
Before the show,
we went through our audience
and picked out two people who
said that they were musicians.
We gave them each
a made-up song title
and gave them an hour to write
an original song
based on that title.
Here's a shot of them practicing
backstage a minute ago.
This is real. Yep. Yeah.
So, I can't wait to see
what they come up with.
Let's meet them right now.
Come on over, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi.
-Hi!
-How you doing?
-Good, how are you?
-Nice to meet you.
-Nice to meet you too.
-Hi. Nice to meet you.
-Sure.
-Welcome to the show.
Welcome, welcome.
-Thanks.
-Alright, here we go. Now, let's
start with contestant number 1.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-My name is Beth Killian.
I'm from Providence,
Rhode Island.
-Yeah! Providence.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Beth Killian.
Beth, what was the title of
the song that you were given?
-The title I was given was
"TikTok in My Flip Flops."
-Ah. "TikTok in My Flip Flops."
And what instrument
will you be playing?
-Guitar.
-Guitar. Alright.
Go set up, and we'll give you
a nice intro there, Beth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get yourself ready.
Take your time. We got this.
Ladies and gentlemen, here to
perform the world premiere
of the soon-to-be classic
"TikTok in My Flip Flops,"
it's Beth Killian!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hey, baby,
it's that time of year ♪
♪ When the sun comes out
and the water is clear ♪
♪ And messages get drowned out
every day ♪
♪ There's an app for that
if you've got something to say ♪
♪ I'll make a TikTok
in my flip flops ♪
♪ Just to get your attention ♪
♪ Do a trendin' dance in sandals
without apprehension ♪
♪ The world might be on fire,
rising tensions ♪
♪ But lay out your towel
for stress prevention ♪
♪ Make this the summer of
TikTok in flip flops ♪
♪ Freezie pops and crop tops ♪
♪ Let the beads of sweat
drip drop ♪
♪ He's a 10, but he voted
against human rights ♪
♪ It's the bodily autonomy
for me, alright? ♪
♪ And it's about damn time ♪
♪ 'Cause in a minute I'm gonna
need you to use your voices ♪
♪ For something good ♪
♪ Keep runnin' up, runnin' up,
up the hill ♪
♪ Like I know you could ♪
♪ No matter your gender, your
size, you're such a hottie ♪
♪ Make a TikTok
in your flip flops ♪
♪ And flaunt that body ♪
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, now!
Fantastic! Get over here.
Give it up for Beth Killian
right there.
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, that was fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Thank you very much.
-Thanks.
-Alright, let's meet
contestant number 2.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name's Jacob Seighman.
I'm from Detroit, Michigan.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love Detroit.
What is your song title?
-Song title is "We're Only
Friends 'Cause You Have a Pool."
[ Laughter ]
-That's relatable.
That's relatable.
Relatable song. What instrument
will you be playing?
-On the keys.
-Yeah! On the keys.
Alright, go set up.
Whenever you're ready to go.
"The keys."
[ Laughs ]
That's awesome. Oh, my gosh.
Jacob's gonna play the keys,
which is musician for piano.
That's -- yeah, yeah. Keyboard.
-Code word.
-That's code. That's right.
That's right.
Ladies and gentlemen, get ready
for the world premiere of
"We're Only Friends
'Cause You Have a Pool,"
by Jacob Seighman.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Mm-hmm ♪
♪ Another June,
and it's hotter than hot ♪
♪ I know it seems
like I like you a lot ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I put on a face and I act
like we're cool, but ♪
♪ We're only friends
'cause you have a pool ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I watch the awful shows
you love to binge ♪
♪ I laugh at your jokes,
even though you are cringe ♪
♪ To be quite honest,
you are kind of a tool, but ♪
♪ I'm so glad that we're friends
'cause you have a pool ♪
♪ When the winter comes around,
I am fully gonna ghost you ♪
♪ If your name comes up in
conversation, I will roast you ♪
♪ Just bein' honest,
I don't mean to be cruel, but ♪
♪ We're only friends
'cause you have a pool ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Not too shabby!
Not too shabby!
Fantastic, buddy.
Thank you.
That was great.
Jacob Seighman right there,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Two very good contestants.
Now it's time to see who won.
We're gonna let our great
audience decide the winner.
Was it contestant number 1?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's good.
Or contestant number 2?
[ Louder cheers and applause ]
There we go!
Looks like contestant number 2
is our winner!
Jacob, congratulations.
-[ Laughs ]
-Jacob, you won
"I love music" sweatshirt.
There you go.
You probably don't have
one of those.
Not bad.
Also, you won
a Samsung Galaxy Book2 Pro
to write and record songs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Sorry.
-It's okay.
-Yeah. No problem.
No. No one goes home
empty handed.
Our other contestant will get
an "I love music" sweatshirt
as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And a Samsung Galaxy Book2 Pro!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Give it up for your two
new Instant Songwriters!